a lot of people think that models wear
makeup all the time but as a matter of
fact when you go to the castings or jobs
people always ask you to have absolutely
no makeup on today my makeup look is a
brown smokey eye a nude lip and some
shimmer on my cheeks I'm wearing a
natural soft look but with a strong brow
got eyes couple shadow and methodical
it's like I'm wearing a really grungy
rock chic makeup really dark eye
clean skin bold brows slight contouring
and I won't let a lot of people in fact
think that we're not real people also
people don't realize that there is a
huge team behind that picture it may be
up to 20 people on set and I'm just
talking about photoshoot the show could
be a hundred it's a big process and it's
not only up to me thanks to all these
people for so talented so yeah there is
a big work behind all of these pretty
pictures a hard thing in this industry
is comparison but really it can apply it
to everyone especially this day and age
with social media being what it is a lot
of girls get skinny shamed some girls
are naturally skinny you just have to
remember that everyone's different even
though I think I'm the skinny and so
they think like I don't have pimples
that I do when I grow up my mom says
that it's not makeup who makes you
beautiful by what is inside from
modeling I start to learn English
talking with people and I enjoy every
second they are thinking that model in
life you wearing all this amazing
clothes or champagne all the time
because I was a girl it's like this but
not for everyone you waking up around 6
7 o'clock in the morning you have to be
at work already and then you're shooting
all day and then you're going home some
of the girls are working out some of the
girls just you know like to spend their
time
families yeah that's basically the daily
honestly I don't feel beautiful every
day sometimes I have bad skin days when
I travel a lot or work a lot sometimes I
have bad hair days and I just want to
cuddle up under my shades and just watch
Netflix the whole day we have our own
insecurities and we're not perfect
because of my work I have to stay in a
certain shape which is very slim you
know very fit but it's not considered to
be sexy in the society what sexy is
big-boobs big-butt you know some curves
but I don't have that and sometimes I
want to have that because I want to feel
sexy like the other girls on the beach
but I'm just like this flat girl when I
want to feel sexy it's like playing on
high heels I don't care what everybody
thinks I'm told in the building there's
this one quote that I always really love
it's called comparison is the thief of
joy and it's very true and I think that
took me a little bit of time to realize
because it's really easy to get down on
yourself being older than a lot of the
models who I work with over time you
kind of just learn to roll with the
punches more but I think you have to
embrace who you are and what you bring
to the table because I think that will
ultimately make you a more successful
and happier model in person finally I
change my hairstyle because I was
wearing my long hair with extensions
three years ago the black model news a
lot expansion to do these choices easily
chops so now I think the market is more
open to you on her they actually know
they love a lot so that's why I change
they show my natural hand everybody
loved it now I grew up and I know that's
every kind of hair they can be beautiful
in the beginning when the kids are young
they can say a lot of things but when
they're gonna grow up a lot of people
will be jealous that you red hair a lot
of people will be so jealous of your
freckles every different person every
day
shape of the face it requires a
completely different makers like good
makeup completely depend on good makeup
artist as a kid I always got made fun of
for being too tall too skinny and I just
wanted to fit in and look the same I
really hated my eyebrows because they
were so dark and so thick but today this
is what's in right now so it works
perfectly for me basically all my
friends in the industry had similar
experiences so I was so happy when I
first started modeling to realize that
there were other people in the world
going through the same thing maybe when
I'm done no modelling I'm just gonna
sugary die and get some boobs and ass
and just rock or some faint one